[Musique]
notre invité est un grand nom de
l'écriture on peut le dire il fait
partie des stars du roman ces livres
sont systématiquement en tête des ventes
et pourtant pourtant rien n'était écrit
chez lui on ne lisait pas beaucoup son
avenir il l'avait d'abord écrit en
musique avec sa guitare son premier
roman ce même un peu in extremis qu'il
parvient à le publier et puis un jour un
livre le livre la délicatesse c'est le
tournant la consécration le succès
populaire est l'enchaînement des prix
mais ça ne lui suffira pas il sert
ensuite à une autre écriture scène du
cinéma le carton là encore à croire que
l'art est une seconde nature chez lui
alors plutôt que romancier préfère-t-il
être présenté comme un artiste on va lui
poser la question bienvenue dans un
monde un regard bienvenue david
foenkinos merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ici au sénat dans ce dom
tournon auteur entre autres de numéro 2
chez gallimard on en parlera vous
qualifiez finalement d'écrivains de
romancier c'est presque un peu réducteur
non
non enfin merci pour cette belle
présentation ce très beau lieu s'est
passé pas réducteur parce que c'est
vraiment ce que je mettrai en premier
parfois on me le monde est ce que je
peux faire réaliser des films faire du
théâtre avec la pièce de théâtre ou
écrire des romans c'est vrai que
l'écriture romanesque c'est vraiment le
coeur de ma vie mais le point commun
entre tout ça c'est quand même une soif
d'expression qu'est ce que vous avez à
ce point envie de nous dire besoin de me
dire mais je crois que ça tout le monde
a besoin de s'exprimer de n'importe
quelle manière que cela puisse être moi
j'ai très vite compris enfin à partir de
16 17 ans que après avoir tenté la
musique parfois même la peinture ou
d'autres choses improbables c'était
vraiment avec les mots que j'arrivais à
exprimer mes émotions et peut-être aller
au plus haut plus proche de ce que je
ressentais donc ce que j'ai à dire c'est
variable parce que j'ai alterné des
livres où j'étais dans la gravité dans
la profondeur dans la mélancolie parfois
de parler voilà deux d'artistes qui me
touchait et puis à d'autres moments j'ai
écrit des livres plus léger donc ça
alterne selon mes humeurs et mes
émotions mais est ce que vous craignez
parfois que la source se tarit ce que
vous ne trouviez plus l'inspiration vous
voulez que
j'imagine que cela entre alors peut être
pas vraiment à vrai dire
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup travaillé depuis
certaines années et je crois qu'il est
temps pour moi aussi de voilà deux je
vais pas dire faire une pause mais en
tout cas de régénérer
d'une manière générale j'ai jamais
essayé de refaire ce que j'avais déjà
fait tous mes livres sont très très
différentes soit la délicatesse
charlotte le mystère hippiques j'ai
besoin de me renouveler d'être dans la
réinvention permanente
donc je pense que pour être dans cette
énergie là il faut il faut détendre pose
donc je ne suis pas dans mon travail
s'impose là vous nous dites que vous
allez faire une pause j'aimerais bien
mais j'aimerais bien ça me laisse le
temps de venir vous voir c'est parfait
de combien de temps vous avez une idée
non je ne sais pas ce qu'ils font des
choses pour avoir à nouveau de
l'inspiration à ses avis et c'est
absolument primordiale et c'est vrai que
moi je me nourris beaucoup des moments
je veux dire de promotion où je voyage
je rencontre les gens je rencontre les
lecteurs c'est très grande nourriture
pour pouvoir un prêt retourner dans sa
ternie dans sa tanière c'est à dire mon
lit et d'écrire dans la solitude l'inde
l'un se nourrit forcément de l'autre
mais je pense que
fin l'expression artistique c'est tout
sauf systématique on peut être très bien
capable de réussir un roman de touche et
peut-être les gens et puis aussi moins
après dans l'incapacité d'être dans la
capacité d'écrire trois phrases donc il
ya quelque chose de l'or de la fragilité
et je pense que elle se nourrit aussi du
silence du retrait donc c'est bien aussi
d'avoir des moments de repli vu votre
succès vous considérez comme un artiste
populaire où l'expression vous dérange
bon maintenant
populaire ne me dérange pas du tout
populaire ça veut dire pour avoir
beaucoup de lecteurs ce qui me
dérangerait c'est de vouloir à tout prix
capitaliser ou garder mes lecteurs ou
d'aller chercher l'électorat j'écris un
roman comme charlotte juste après la
délicatesse qui est un roman écrit en
verre sur un sujet extrêmement
douloureux à ce moment là je suis
certain que les lecteurs ne m'ont ne
vont jamais me suivre sur un tel projet
donc j'ai pas une obsession de la
popularité au contraire j'ai plutôt à
chaque fois essayé de de surprendre
d'aller ailleurs quitte à décontenancer
j'ai certains de mes lecteurs qui me
disent bon celui-ci j'aime moins mais au
moins voilà deux ils vont lire le
prochain en se demandant ce que je vais
faire donc c'est pas pour moi une je me
rêvais pas tous les matins en ayant
cette notion-là en tête c'est plutôt en
ayant
l'interrogation de qu'est ce que je vais
pouvoir écrire comment je vais pouvoir
exprimer ce que je ressens et on parlera
de charlotte tout à l'heure parce que
c'est l'une de vos oeuvres majeures mais
avant cela j'ai envie de vous proposer
un petit jeu est de vous confier cette
archive je vais vous lire un texte que
les archives nationales nous ont
transmis vous me dîtes si vous en
deviner l'auteur et c'est pas trop
regarder combien il est réconfortant
pour des hommes qui comme nous sont
engagés dans de dures épreuves de se
trouver ensemble coude à coude l'esprit
fixé sur la même pensée le coeur battant
de la même ardeur vous avez une idée de
qui a écrit ça
j'ai pas j'essaye de voir son mais les
nets
non je sais pas ça faisait ça pour être
cohen ça pourrait annoncer gré vous que
c'est général de gaulle assez de gaulle
ouais ce sont ces corrections à leurs
discours du 18 juin 1940 qu'elle était
lors du troisième anniversaire de
l'appel du 18 juin justement d'où cette
question est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut être un bon écrivain pour être un
bon politique est-ce qu'il faut être un
bon écrivain un bon pour moi c'est très
important le rapport entre la politique
et la littérature sont sans parler de
mes convictions personnelles manger j'ai
apprécié les les présidents ou en tout
cas les sommes en capacité de diriger
certaine et certaines fonctions en ayant
une grande valeur littéraire qui ont pu
mettre le livre au coeur de certaines de
leurs de leurs actions de leurs pensées
leurs façons d'être alors évidemment on
pense à mitterrand qui est qui était
vraiment animé par la culture littéraire
et d'ailleurs la plupart des écrivains
kilkee qu'il aimait ne sont fins on peut
lui maintenant comme comme chardonne par
exemple sont beaucoup moins lui mais il
était de cette tradition cette tradition
littéraire ça c'est très important j'ai
chez moi la photo de mitterrand de 1981
le portrait officiel devant une
bibliothèque
est alors toujours sur cette archive ya
un passage intéressant à l'origine il
avait écrit je le cite toujours cela
surtout dans un moment où les brouillard
artificiel pourrait risquer de nous
égarer et ils corrigent
il marche sur cette archive que le
public voit aussi en écrivant on parlait
d'union pour l'interrogation l'union la
voilà on a l'impression que le politique
reprend le dessus sur sur l'écrivain et
que tout d'un coup la formule un peu
poétique disparaît au profit du slogan
ce qui m'amène à vous demander si vous
souhaitez qu'on est dans une période où
effectivement
on a le sens de la formule on écrit coup
on écrit concis et c'est un peu moins
poétique vous avez en tout cas ya
beaucoup de politiques qui se qui se
rêve écrivain mitterrand l'a dit un
maquereau évidemment juillet ggv
souvenir d'une interview de brigitte m'a
conquis par les deux d'emmanuel
maquereau en disant qu' il aurait voulu
être écrivain peut-être qu'il le sera
par la suite
on voit bien qu'il ya quand même un
rapport très très fort il est évident
que il me semble que l'action le désir
d'action suplon totalement la la rêverie
et la m hélas le rapport aux mots à la
littérature et que c'est très
symptomatique de ce texte qui est au
bout d'un moment voilà mais là en plus
on en 1943 donc il ya peut être autre
chose à faire que d'écrire un nouveau
roman mais mais ça me paraît évident que
il faut presque j'allais dire une sorte
de goût de l'inaction pour être écrivain
ce qui est un peu antinomique avec la
fonction politique vous auriez aimé
mettre votre écriture au profit du
politique ou pas du tout
j'adore la politique 20 ans j'adore
rencontrer les politiques ça me
passionne
j'ai vraiment j'aime beaucoup discuté
quand j'ai l'occasion voilà j'ai cette
chance en tant qu'écrivain de pouvoir
être invité parfois j'ai une fascination
comme ça pour le pour l'engagement pour
la difficulté que ça peut représenter
contrairement à beaucoup je me sens
animé comme pas par respect pour la
plupart des politiques pour autant mais
votre question c'était de savoir si moi
non moi je suis vraiment je pense
l'homme le moins engagé le moins je
pense que je me sens je me complais
totalement dans le non seulement dans la
rêverie mais la plupart de mes romans
sont totalement fictionnel g parle je
parle très peu du contemporain mes films
aussi j'ai besoin de voyager de moi même
ce qui ne ne veut pas dire je ne suis
pas en phase totalement avec le concret
mais pour moi la création c'est une
sorte d'adultère du quotidien l'écriture
vous vient aussi après des heures
d'ennui et d'oisiveté et d'ailleurs vous
le dit un peu dans numéro 2 vous écrivez
ce si difficile d'imaginer une existence
plus mornes mais l'ennui demeure la
meilleure formation pour écrire vous le
pensez c'est un vécu et c'est aussi un
message aux parents qui cherchent un peu
les emplois du temps des enfants et les
empêche de s'ennuyer il ya quelque chose
de sain derrière je suis pas là pour
passer des messages ou non et dirigeants
mais je veux plus en plus je suis très
très mal passé puisque moi en tant que
père de deux enfants et notamment avec
ma fille je sens que des cadres deux
minutes de de non activité j'essaie de
réfléchir à tout ce qui est fait est
fait c'est vrai qu'on est vraiment on a
je pense que notre époque à tuer ou à
tenter de tuer l'ennui est que c'est pas
forcément bénéfique j'avais écrit à
quelques années un lit chaud john lennon
et raconter à quel point rien ne pouvait
être plus ennuyeux que l'angleterre des
années 50 et que ça a éveillé chez lui
le goût de la littérature de lewis
carroll de la poésie de la rêverie et
sûrement sa vocation artistique donc ça
me paraît évident que parfois oui le
temps et à ne rien faire c'est un temps
extrêmement constructif et je dis ça en
tant qu'écrivain qui est l'alibi absolue
prendrait à faire on peut passer des
journées à rester dans son lit à
regarder le plafond et est à dire qu'on
est en train de travailler vous parlez
de john lennon et puis je parlais de
votre goût pour la musique tout à
l'heure mais vous y vous y êtes essayé à
la musique vous avez été prof de guitare
et la journée et serveurs le soir je
crois vous avez même rêvé d'être
contraire mais vous avez rêvé d'être une
rock star vous avez saint siège avait
pas cette ambition mais même après quand
j'ai commencé à écrire je n'ai jamais
rêvé ni d'être publié une lettre un
auteur à succès c'était une expression
liées à la nécessité
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup effet de fait de
musique j'ai je voulais être musicien à
un moment donné puis finalement j'ai
parfois dick jeu devenu écrivain parce
que je trouvais pas de bassiste mais la
vie était contre moi rien ne marche et
puis j'étais certainement pas assez doué
et je pense que c'est mieux pour tout le
monde je devais mettre assez pathétique
par moments mais un mais je crois
qu'entre 15 et 25 ans comme beaucoup
d'adolescents j'ai cherché ma voie
d'expression et progressivement
l'écriture les mots se sont imposés non
seulement comme une évidence mais comme
la nécessité absolue de toute chose sauf
que ce n'était pas forcément gagné le
succès de l'écriture ça va pas arriver
tout de suite ni très facilement je
crois vous direz si je me trompe ou pas
mais que beaucoup d'éditeurs refuse
votre premier roman et c'est gallimard
qui va se positionner qui va vous publié
en 2002 et s'était plutôt bien senti
puisque ce livre inversion de l'idiotie
va recevoir le prix françois mauriac
prix décerné par l'académie française
rien que ça est-ce que ça a été une
petite revanche sur tous les éditeurs
qui vous avez dit non alors c'est un
prix très prestigieux mais ça reste
assez confidentiel et c'était c'était un
très beau témoignage mais moi je n'en
revenais pas c'est vrai que j'ai envoyé
mon manuscrit tout le monde l'a refusée
et puis il ya un éditeur chez gallimard
qui est tombée sur ce texte jean marie
laclavetine bien plus tard j'ai lu sa
note de lecture qui disait c'est
bordélique c'est foutraque mais ça vaut
le coup d'essayer après j'ai été
tellement heureux pendant une dizaine
d'années j'ai publié en ayant très peu
de lecteurs mais je trouvais ça déjà
merveilleux mais j'ai connu cette
traversée un peu étrange j'ai connu ces
salons du livre où tout le monde vient
vous voir en vous demandant où sont les
toilettes ou certaines certaines
certaines rencontres les terres assez
assez avec avec très peu de personnes
présentes mais ça me rendait vraiment
heureux voilà de pouvoir
de pouvoir m'exprimer par l'écriture
mais quel regard vous avez sur ce monde
de l'écriture ce monde de l'édition vous
parliez des salons est ce que c'est un
monde un peu frileux qui prend peu de
risques est ce qu'il faut que les
maisons d'édition soit libre audacieuse
indépendante j'ai un regard moins très
complet parce que j'ai 20 ans derrière
moi deux publications en ayant tous
connus c'est à dire des livres encensé
par la critique mais ne se vendront pas
des livres qui dépasse un million
d'exemplaires et qui peuvent susciter le
suspect des livres qui sont à la fois
parfois ont été des succès et qui ont eu
des grands prix littéraires donc j'ai
j'ai vraiment connu toutes les types de
possibilité d'un écrivain le droit
il me semble que c'est plus difficile
maintenant c'est plus difficile il ya
vingt ans quand j'ai publié mon premier
roman même si c'était pas du tout
comment dire un succès j'ai même
l'impression qu'on pouvait exister il y
avait eu l'audace et un roman absurdes
ou simplement louve un roman loufoque
il y avait une exposition quand même
auprès des médias on pouvait on pouvait
j'ai le sentiment un peu existé c'est
beaucoup plus dur maintenant pourquoi
qu'est ce qui a changé il ya toujours
autant de romans on parle beaucoup des
auteurs qui effectivement on une lumière
médiatique ont eu du succès ou non des
prix littéraires mais c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus difficile d'émerger parce
qu'il ya moins d'espacé parce qu'il ya
peut-être moins de curiosité mais est ce
que vous faites un lien justement avec
ce changement de public
et l'apparition et très dominante des
écrans par exemple est-ce que ça ça peut
ça a pu changer modifier le public et
les lecteurs non parce que beaucoup
beaucoup de gens lisent on sent pas une
érosion du lectorat on sent qu'elle se
focalise sur certains auteurs et qu'il
ya peut-être moins de curiosité paul
pour des auteurs émergents la véritable
érosion elle et elle est clairement au
niveau du cinéma ou les écrans font que
voilà les plateformes ont vraiment
grignoter le terrain de rebondir de des
cinémas sas afin de lui fait d'aller au
cinéma je pense que c'est vraiment le
secteur qui souffre le plus actuellement
alors parlons-en du cinéma parce que
c'est aussi votre univers votre monde
l'écriture cinématographique
c'est compliqué de voir une oeuvre qu'on
a écrite pour le roman pour un public
lecteur de le voir se transformer en
image est ce que c'est toujours à la
hauteur de ce que vous aviez vous
imaginé non parfois c'est pas du tout à
la hauteur voit parfois si elle est même
plus con ce qu'on espérait le mot roman
par exemple le mystère en epic adapté
par aimiez besoins sont là camille
cottin et fabrice luchini j'ai trouvé
très réussi quand jean paul rouve a fait
les souvenirs je me souviens il m'a dit
je pense je pense à annie cordy pour la
pour la grand mère s'était pas du tout
ma première idée la première impression
il a fait un film absolument
bouleversant donc parfois ça peut ça
peut être de belles surprises j'ai eu
cette chance-là moi j'avais adapté la
délicatesse avec mon frère on avait on a
vu la chance d'avoir le duo dre toutou
françois damiens mais je comprends que
ce soit très compliqué pour des lecteurs
qui aiment un livre qui n'ont pas
forcément envie de confronter leur
propre vision à celle d'un cinéaste très
souvent chaque lecteur se fait son
propre film et oui visualise donc c'est
peut-être un peu étrange moi j'ai
certains de mes livres comme vers la
beauté par exemple je n'ai pas voulu que
d'adaptation pour le moment je n'ai pas
un gênait pas pour obsession que tous
mes livres deviennent des films loin de
là j'en ai eu quatre ça me paraît déjà
très très bien mais j'aime vraiment que
le roman de moeurs une chose personnelle
et puis le terrain de liberté absolue
pour le lecteur récemment dans l'ue et
vous avez dit ceci alors que j'ai
toujours eu le sentiment que mes romans
étaient différents les uns des autres
j'ai compris récemment qu'il reflétait
tout ce que j'ai traversé lors de mon
hospitalisation mais livre parle si
souvent de reconstruction de l'idée de
survivre à une épreuve est ce que c'est
ça le point commun à toutes vos oeuvres
c'est la reconstruction la fragilité la
vulnérabilité mais complètement mais je
n'en reviens pas d'avoir mis autant de
temps à le comprendre
quand j'avais publié la délicatesse et
est l'histoire d'une femme qui perdait
son mari et qui a pris rencontré un
suédois dépressif j'avais reçu tellement
de l'être cette époque ou de messages
sur facebook de gens qui me disaient
comment vous avez pu ressentir
ça puis après j'ai écrit charlotte qui
parle d'une artiste qui traverse
tellement d'épreuves et qui va chercher
au plus profond d'elle même la beauté
pour pouvoir survivre et ainsi de suite
et je me suis rendu compte que tous mes
romans aussi différentes puisse-t-il
être étaient tous traversés par par
cette nécessité de se réinventer souvent
par la création de trouver ne voit là
une sorte de seconde vie d'être animée
par une seconde vie et j'avais
transposer d'une manière totalement
inconsciente ma propre expérience une
expérience de maladie de morts est de
retour à la vie progressivement et donc
tous mes romans finalement même s'ils
sont totalement différents travers cette
cette idée le dernier roman parle
d'échec est de retour en fin de son
concert après un échec c'est une
nouvelle version de la même histoire et
on verra mais je suis une arnaque totale
en fait et à une époque c'est d'autant
plus fort on est dans une époque où
effectivement on nous demande à tous
d'être fort tout le temps d'être assez
invulnérable et vous vous parlait de
vulnérabilité
oui c'est assez juste dans une époque
peut-être encore plus oui avec les
réseaux sociaux je montre de ce qui va
bien tu exactement va bien on est
heureux ouais c'est parfois un peu
déprimant d'être dans le métro
dans la grisaille et puis on voit déjà
en train de siroter des cocktails à
saint barth sur instagram ça peut être
effectivement
parfois un peu un peu étrange disons
qu'en tout cas on en a il ya toujours eu
cette notion d'échec et de réussite
toujours mais là ce qui change dans
notre époque c'est que il ya cette
notion de comparaison qui est qui est
clairement accru puisque avec les
réseaux sociaux on vit sous la dictature
du bonheur des autres enfin du prétendu
bonheur des autres donc il ne suffit pas
il ne suffit pas d'avoir un rapport à sa
propre réussite wascon rate mais on est
inconsciemment propulser vers le bas la
comparaison avec ce que vivent les
autres et c'est vrai que ça c'est le
sujet central de mon livre puisque mon
personnage qui n'a n'a pas été choisi
pour être harry potter a en permanence
la vie de l'autre botia il ya cette
notion que c'est déjà difficile de rater
les choses mais d'avoir en plus le
succès des autres qui vous hante ou qui
vous sautent au visage ça ça rajoute la
complexité pourquoi avoir choisi
d'écrire sur le numéro 2 plutôt que le
numéro 1 pourquoi c'est cette partie là
qui vous à qui vous a convaincu
effectivement numéro 2 parle de ceux de
ce jeune qui loupe le casting à la
dernière limite sur la dernière marche
il est en finale et il va passer des
années à observer le succès de l'autre
pourquoi s'être intéressé à ce numéro 2
est ce que ça vous renvoie quelque chose
de vous will casting d'harry potter
a pas forcément en tout cas moi j'ai une
tendresse pour peut-être pour ceux qui
ratent les choses il est clair que ce
petit garçon j'ai une empathie totale
pour lui je me dis qu'il a dû imaginer
qu'il allait devenir une star de cinéma
il faut savoir qu à l'époque ce que je
raconte dans le livre ils ont auditionné
des centaines d'acteurs le film à
l'écouté sont millions de dollars on
parlait déjà de faire une saga le livre
devenu un phénomène il fallait vraiment
pas se tromper pour savoir qui serait
harry potter et donc à la fin ils ont
hésité entre deux et j'imagine que ce
petit garçon voilà ça doit être
effroyable pour lui d'être écarté au
dernier moment et donc c'est des plus
animées par set cette empathie et donc
pour moi c'est au-delà d'être numéro 2
qui est le titre du livre j'avais envie
de parler de l'échec d'une manière
générale et de 2 lits des ces communes
finalement de qu'on doit forcément
traversé ou les chèques ou de rater des
choses pour pouvoir réussir par la suite
que c'est une épreuve sûrement
nécessaire vous avez aussi écrit sur le
grand âge les personnes âgées nos aînés
dans un moment où on s'interroge sur la
façon dont on les traite dont on les
malmène aussi parfois nos aînés
qu'est-ce que quel est votre regard vous
sur
ces débats et cette façon dont on traite
nos aînés est-ce qu'on se trompait ce
conte c'est une question très très très
difficile je trouve effectivement j'ai
écrit un livre là-dessus qu'ils
s'appellent les souvenirs ou qui étaient
totalement lié à ma propre expérience
elle convie tous c'est à dire que moi
j'ai accompagné mes grands mères pendant
assez longtemps donc j'avais deux fois
par semaine dans les maisons de retraite
donc bien sûr on parle de on parle de
certaines personnes qui tentent de faire
des profits et à une sorte de
maltraitance qui est tout simplement
insupportable et qui nous violente tous
parce que c'est notre destin à tous que
ce soit notre destin proches où que
voilà on a dans notre entourage
c'est moi j'ai été vraiment animé par
une colère et je me suis senti vraiment
bouleversée et en même temps j'ai des
souvenirs moins
de femmes et d'hommes aussi
extraordinaire qui a accompagné les
personnes âgées c'est un métier
difficile j'ai vu aussi beaucoup de
bienveillance j'ai vu que moi j'ai
souvenir de ma première qui adorent et
les personnes qui l'accompagnaient dans
une dans des établissements modeste et
donc donc il faut pas non plus d'un coup
tous voient la ccsn je ne ferai pas le
modèle qui pose problème est-ce que
c'est pas tout un modèle à revoir toute
une façon de réintroduire ces personnes
âgées contente de mettre à l'écart dans
des espaces où on les voit peu une fois
par semaine et encore quand on a envie
d'aller les voir les réintégrer dans
notre société c'est intéressant parce
qu'on avait beaucoup à l'époque de la
canicule il y avait 20 ans on avait dit
mais comment est-ce possible dans une
société occidentale occidental je me
souviens que houellebecq avait avait dit
dans une interview c'est justement parce
qu on est dans une société occidentale
qui s'est passé ça parce que sinon dans
d'autres sociétés on garde avec nous les
personnes âgées donc c'est pas du tout
de même rapport et c'est un
questionnement qui de toute façon on ne
va pas cessé d'être au coeur de notre de
notre vie à chacun avec le
vieillissement de la population donc il
est ça me paraît évident que si
certaines personnes peuvent accompagner
au rester avec les personnes âgées il
faut le faire ça c'est certain mais ça
paraît plus facile à dire qu'à faire et
puis c'est une question de moyens c'est
une question très très compliqué je
pense que c'est un c'est un enjeu majeur
des prochaines des prochaines décennies
donc
voilà je pense que la polémique actuelle
et la violence de ce qu'on découvre
actuellement moi j'ai été bouleversé on
a parlé de françoise dorin
sa famille qui a témoigné c'est une
femme que j'ai connus qui était
tellement dans la vie généreuse qui
s'intéressait aux jeunes écrivains enfin
c'est c'est pas possible de finir comme
ça c'est au niveau de la dignité donc
donc je suis toujours très très très
faim ça me paraît très important que ces
questions là reviennent de manière
récurrente au coeur de l'actualité je
vais vous proposer quelques photos david
foenkinos
c'est aussi une habitude dans cette
émission même bien confronter notre
invité à des photos la première la voix
si on en a déjà parlé cette fois c'est
une photo de charlotte salomon une
peintre juive allemande morte à
auschwitz en 43 à laquelle vous avez
donc consacré ce roman dont vous parliez
charlotte en 2014 qui va être un immense
succès en librairie finalistes du prix
goncourt je crois renaudot goncourt des
lycéens il va obtenir aussi le globe de
cristal du meilleur roman de l'année
2014 votre plus grande fierté c'est quoi
c'est ce succès ou le fait d'avoir sorti
de l'oubli cette femme et qu'il y ait eu
des commémorations qu'elle soit réapparu
dans
dans le collectif les deux les deux sont
liés mais c'est évident que c est nominé
dans l'ain vide d'un artiste ou d'un
homme ou d'une femme tout simplement de
pouvoir à un moment donné mettre en
lumière quelqu'un qu'on admire il faut
savoir comment j'étais obsédé par elle
mais d'une mètres d'une belle manière
elles me fascinent éparses paréage ans
pour moi c'était un artiste hors norme
et j'étais désespéré de voir à quel
point elle était elle était oubliée elle
était très peu connu pour moi elle était
un exemple inouïe de femmes courageuses
qui
alors qu'elle est au bord du désespoir
qu'elle est en exil dans le sud de la
france va chercher au plus profond
d'elle même la beauté l'intelligence la
culture pour créer une oeuvre
extraordinaire donc le succès de mon
livre qui a permis aux gens de la
découvrir en grande partie ça a été la
plus grande émotion de ma vie littéraire
et notamment quand j'ai obtenu le
goncourt des lycéens parce que je trouve
qu'elle était un exemple très important
aussi pour la jeunesse et je suis
toujours bouleversée de voir que le
livre ait beaucoup étudié à l'école ça
c'est très très important donc c'était
c'était un devoir de mémoire mais
au-delà de ça une volonté de weck on
n'oublie pas cette artiste ça aurait pu
passer inaperçue ça a plu pourquoi
d'après vous qu'est-ce qui a pu plaire
en fait on ne sait jamais pourquoi les
choses si on le savait on le ferait
peut-être avant je me souviens quand
j'avais publié la délicatesse qui avait
dépassé un million d'exemplaires un
journaliste avait écrit c'est normal se
livrent à toutes les recettes du succès
à l'époque j'avais 35 ans je vivais dans
un deux pièces avec mon fils si je
connaissais les recettes du succès
j'aurais déjà fait avant là en
l'occurrence charlotte vraiment le livre
est écrit d'une manière très
particulière c'est une vie suffocante si
douloureuse j'étais persuadé que les
lecteurs ne me suivrait pas mais je me
suis dit si 1000 2000 personnes vont
lire ce livre ça va être merveilleux 6
avec chaque personne qui va découvrir
c'était beauxis et puis voilà il ya
quelque chose dedans
dans le livre je pense qu'au delà de mon
livre les gens sont aussi bouleversée
par ce destin quand on y mon livre on
découvre une vie incroyable une vie de
souffrance certes mais une vie qui a
animé par le par la volonté de de
s'extirper du mal-être autre destin
tragique brisé qui là aussi vous a
fasciné puisque vous l'avez dit vous lui
avait consacré un livre à john lennon
vous avez dit un jour il me bouleversait
par sa fragilité me fascinait à cause de
son amour fusionnel avec yoko ono malgré
la célébrité il a été en permanence dans
un état de souffrance il n'a trouvé
l'apaisement cac 40 ans avant d'être
assassiné dites vous ce sont décidément
les destins tragiques qui vous qui vous
fascine vous oui alors la tragédie
n'était pas pour moi le point commun
c'est surtout la fascination artistique
c'est à dire que je refaire le monde je
l'avais rennais j'avais pardon charlotte
salomon j'avais une vénération total
pour son poisson pour son oeuvre kim kim
bouleversait que je trouvais si brillant
intellectuellement et là en l'occurrence
jeu j'ai toujours eu halal depuis l'âge
de 15 ans une émotion incroyable en
écoutant les beatles comme temps doux
flamand il ya un terrain de
d'exceptionnel mais la poésie la
fragilité de john lennon me touchait
particulièrement et l'évidence que les
donc cette vie est marquée par la
tragédie mais elle est surtout marquée
par une par une fêlure par un amour
impossible à rassasier tous les gens qui
ont été abandonnés ressentent ça et
c'est que c'est un enfant qui qui a été
abandonné et qui malgré la gloire malgré
l'aura internationale malgré le génie
qui semble coulait dans ses veines
est quelque chose qui n'est jamais pensé
jusqu'au moment où il rencontre locaux
nos autres sujets qui me fascinait dans
son histoire est-ce que c'est l absolue
c'était de se dire qu'à un moment donné
voilà en étant fixé d'une manière qui a
rendu fou tous les autres personnes
l'entourage les beatles forcément parce
que il a estimé que tous les deux ne
formait à présent qu'une seule personne
donc ce mythe romantique aussi c'est
vrai me
bouleversait on va conclure cette
émission avec une séquence qu'on a
l'habitude de faire dans un monde un
regard c'est vous l'avez peut-être
remarqué on est entouré de quatre
statues qui chacune représente tu on a
ici la sagesse la prudence ici la
justice est derrière moi l'éloquence et
j'ai envie de vous demander si peut-être
qu'il n'a pas que l'une de ses vertus
vous correspond vous parle vous
caractérise peut-être alors par rapport
à mon dernier livre je rejouerai
j'aurais aimé mettre en avant la vertu
de l'échec et c'est à dire que voilà il
y arriver il ya une beauté aussi a raté
à apprivoiser à comprendre les choses
donc je ne fais pas les 4 me par je
dirais peut-être la prudence pas parce
que je suis quelqu'un de spécial mais
prudent mais j'ai le sentiment que dans
une époque où tout va tellement vite où
on doit immédiatement analysé les choses
on assassine la nuance voilà avec les
réseaux sociaux j'ai le sentiment que
parfois il faut être prudent dans nos
actes dans notre notre façon de
décrypter de voir le monde donc
j'associerai d'une certaine manière la
prudence à la lenteur mais dans un élan
extrêmement bénéfique de clarté des
choses et beaucoup de choses dites merci
infiniment davidson qui ne méritent
notre invité dans cette émission un
monde un regard merci de vous être livré
comme vous l'avez fait à très vite sur
public ses dents se retrouve la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]